Translating your family tree into
another language should be simple, right?
Just pick a family member and look
up the kinship term. So in some, wow,
your sister is your ouzo
unless you are her brother,
in which case she's your 12th
[inaudible] and for the Ashanti,
your parents nephew is your cousin.
They accept your father's sister's
son who might also get called father.
Clearly there's not just one
way to talk about family,
but the intriguing thing is with
thousands of languages around the world,
there aren't thousands of kinship systems.
In fact,
there may only be a handful.
Let's start with you.
Your generation zero by your side.
You have siblings.
Let's give you a brother and a sister.
One generation up. We meet your
parents, mother and father,
they have their own siblings, your aunts
and your uncles up one more and oh look,
your grandparents, okay,
back to your uncle and aunt.
They're children are down in your
generation and they are all cousins.
No matter which aunt or uncle
on which side of the family,
what we just described is the
Inuits kinship system. No,
not English that we do use this
system. See. Traditionally,
the world's languages are
grouped into six kinship systems.
Languages in this Inuits system treat
close family differently from family to
the side of them,
their collateral kin.
Now imagine if we dropped this
lineal collateral distinction,
the terms for aunt and uncle would become
indistinguishable from the word for
parents and siblings and cousins would
use the same terms for each other,
which is exactly what
happens in Hawaiian kinship.
It cares about something else too.
Are you a brother or a sister?
If your sister to your sister
or brother to your brother,
you use one word taekwondo,
but a brother to a sister
or a sister to a brother.
They have their own brother or sister
words. That's still not enough though.
You also need to respect age.
In Hawaiian,
there's one sameness word for an older
sibling and a different sameness word for
a younger sibling.
The younger brother of a brother or a
younger sister have a sister Archinaut.
Well,
just like English has anyone at kinship.
There are other languages that use the
Hawaiian system to remember the psalm one
word. Ooh, so sometimes shortened to
oops, that's for siblings. Sameness to,
and this can get confusing here.
Let me make you a chart,
save it and please review it before you
ever try and translate brother or sister
in a Mulatto Polynesian language.
Notice how these two systems we've
been using lump terms together.
So many distinct people
under the same word,
cousin as so many different people
getting called Auntie and uncle. Well,
what if we broke these apart?
What if we gave terms to every single
relation from yourself on the tree?
Your wish comes true in the
Sudanese kinship system.
If you studied Latin,
maybe you tried to map ancient family
terms onto your English ones or in at ones
in English.
It's a strange world,
but the old Romans didn't
talk about family that way.
They had distinct terms for each of your
various aunts and uncles and cousins.
Your mother's sister is not
your father's sister. After all,
this isn't just some ancient system today,
Chinese kinship terms aren't
leased as descriptive as this.
Plus they demand you pay attention to age.
Just imagine the piles of basic kinship
terms mandarin has because of this,
I've even read that finding the shortest
path between kin members in your family
answering questions like what
do you call your mother's uncle?
But that gets tricky enough that you're
better off using computer algorithms to
solve it. But Hey, at the very least,
everyone is clearly labeled. Okay,
a simpler one.
Start from our terms,
but then switch up how you
label your parents. Siblings.
Your father's brother
is also called father,
and your mother's sister
is your mother too.
It's their opposite sibling that
gets the auntie uncle status.
Your father's sister is your aunt and
your mother's brother is your uncle.
Logically the children of your mother's
sister and your father's brother become
your siblings,
but your father's sister's children and
your mother's brother's children are
your cousins.
The result is the Iroquois system and
it draws a very clear line between
parallel cousins and cross cousins
right there and the everyday vocabulary.
Why would you want a system like this?
Well,
you might want it if you culturally
pay attention to cross versus parallel
cousins because you consider cross
cousins and marriageable partners,
but you keep your parallel
cousins out of it.
The Ashanti Kingdom and
Ghana have a similar system,
but as the British learned
through experience,
there was a small but critical difference.
The Ashanti King inherits a royal
throne called the golden stool.
British colonizers were eager
to groom some regal allies,
so they sent the king sons away
for a good English education,
but they were left scratching their
heads when the golden stool skipped right
past these princes. See,
when your father passes away,
the next in line to take care
of things is his sister's son.
That's right on his death.
Your cousin becomes your father.
When that happens,
it's a kind of crow kinship.
You're still the uncle and your father's
brother and daunting your mother's
sister,
just like an Iroquois,
but you do something very
interesting on your father's side.
Your father's sister is your aunt.
Okay, but here's where it gets strange.
Her daughter is also
your aunt and her son.
Her son is your father.
It's rare for terms to cut
across generations like
this, but in the cro system,
aunt and father do.
The normal reason given is that crow
kinship pays attention to maternal lines
through the father's sister.
If only the British had known you could
do the opposite of this or the mirror
image.
Start from Iroquois again,
but this time use the same term for your
mother's brother and for your mother's
brother's son calling both of them your
uncle and so who ends up being your
uncle's daughter, the mother's
brother, uncle, not the cousin, uncle.
She is your mother.
This is called Omaha kinship and if
we're going to blame mom's sister for Cro
will chalk this one up
to patrilineal societies.
Earlier on I told you there were
traditionally six kinship systems,
so then we're done.
Hold on.
Consider this kin system from south India.
It seems like just
another Iroquois system,
parallel cousins or siblings
and cross cousins, our cousins.
But watch what happens when we
zoom out and take a wider look.
There's even more crossness going on.
This is Dravidian kinship,
a system that said to prefer across
cousin marriages. It's complicated.
If you focus on you,
but keep that goal of marrying your cross
cousin in mind and go up a generation.
Think about the cross cousins your
parents could have ended up marrying.
Let's circle all the cross
cousins who were there,
potential spouses for your
mother and for your father.
If your parents married one of them
instead their kids would have been your
siblings. You can marry your siblings,
so these are your parallel cousins.
The ones your parents couldn't marry
would give you cross cousins and marriage
material for you.
That is the opposite of what we'd
expect from an Iroquois system.
Father's male cousin and mothers,
female cousin.
Having kids that are your parallel cousins
while they're opposite cousins have
kids who are across cousins to you.
Well there you have it.
Our world's seven kinship systems.
At least that's the traditional count,
but before I let you go,
what about these questions that kept
coming up is I spent my nights researching
kinship for you.
What about systems that are hybrids that
don't quite fit or are even seemingly
untranslatable. Also, why
do these systems exist?
Where did they come from? Finally,
I've been using family trees.
But what if our assumptions are wrong
and these terms aren't really about
genealogy or ancestry.
Now,
I don't mean to sell you a rug
just to pull it out from under you,
but these questions would
make a great followup,
which is something you can vote for.
If you are my patron on Patrion,
you can grab some unique rewards and
stay updated about native laying.
Like this time I posted about a
kin term explorer I coded for you.
If you're a patron,
you should definitely come try it out.
Thank you to patrons for voting for this
video and to everyone. Until next time,
may you and your family stick
around and subscribed for language.